sponsored video world of tanks
as you guys know i am the greatest world
of tanks player in the world
downloading drink is description wait
what is this
oh god no that actually looks pretty
sick not gonna lie
i will not be canceled today thank you
let's go
use code pewdiepie check out and get 14
days premium
let's do this let me show you how good i
am
all right that one doesn't count
all right i'm [ __ ] hyped dude the
sweets will show streets
hey world of tanks if you need a swedish
voice over let me know
so i actually know all the tips and
tricks the developers have taught me how
to suck less at this game
if i can get it if i can get one kill
i'll be satisfied
oh i found you see perfect shot
okay maybe come on come on come on
quack quack
was that my kill i didn't get it
come on come on oh i can't shoot a swede
can't do it it goes against every moral
fiber of my body and i have none of it
spotted oh [ __ ] are the japanese i
can't i can't shoot the japanese what is
that oh
i don't know what country that is but
you're gonna die oh it's french yeah
yeah yeah
yeah you're dead sorry french people if
you're watching
oh i missed on purpose sweden i missed
you on purpose don't shoot back i missed
them perfect
i actually don't know how to reload so
it's better for me to just empty my
magazine oh
[ __ ] off like hiding spot
they'll never get me here all right
reload
sorry doobly
yeah you're supposed to aim at the
bottom that's always good
that's what sun tzu said another one
come on reload real real real real real
up
honestly it's so hard to play this game
this is already a huge win
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
help come on steal the kill steal the
kill
ah wait what oh he's behind me
oh oops sorry
it wasn't my fault i swear
i'm the worst team player all right
we're trying out a new tank
at the abundant target trap retreat
whoa tank will fly now
sun tzu said that trust me hey what are
you doing
don't mind me here we go chinese go by
sorry that was from our website i
totally did not steal that kill that was
all me thank you're welcome guys
oh easy kill
what the hell on just die bro just die
this is embarrassing
are you serious are you kidding me
all right new move
swedish strategy don't worry about it
the problem is every time i go anywhere
i just die
i have absolutely no talent for this
game
oh here we go hey
i take all that back
whoa who's shooting i'm going in
what up boy i know where to aim [ __ ]
i think no no i'm reloading i'm
reloading
oh he's not oh this is my kill this is
my kill this is my kill this is my kill
i'm going i'm going go go go don't shoot
sweetie
dude no team players whatsoever i'm
doing
all the work oh
yeah i'm doing all the work
i'm sorry i'm sorry for teammates if
you're watching the video
i apologize sorry japan
come on come on come on dude i'm the
greatest
four kills no no no no save me save me
save me save me save me i'm sorry
they gave me these super good tanks i
can just repair whatever
[Laughter]
it's my best game please please please
don't shoot swedish
if you die you die i said that remember
that kids
and also download world of tanks use
code pewdiepie
get one premium tank excelsior british
tier five
sun tzu said that but also it works
where the hell are you going some people
are just crazy dude
you know you're gonna die yeah
what did i say hey where are they oh
oh no nope nope i'm not doing that
i'm not going near that [ __ ] i'm not
falling for that oh my god
this is so typical
the bridge the bridge is cursed the
[ __ ] bridge is cursed
who would have guessed it all right
trying out a new tank
i think that it gets harder the bigger
tank you get you they kind of gave me
all the tanks
which i think is a mistake because i'm
so bad at this maps are cool though i
like it
it looks great like look at that
architecture
it's beautiful gorgeous
i was aiming for the bird i promise
[Applause]
jesus christ
oh dang it i could have gotten that
[Music]
yeah what are you doing what is he doing
oh my god i can't aim
don't shoot i'm swedish i'm just gonna
kill oh
okay so it's really good aiming at the
cogwheel he can't move now no wait he
repaired uh-oh
all right all right i'm just going for
the kill don't shoot thank you
thank you
why is he not shooting me is he not
that's all right i got plenty of help
it's fine it doesn't count if you have
plenty of health gamers everyone knows
that
i said that
oh he's not hitting me see if you uh
stay straight towards them sometimes
like a shot just ricochet i said that
because i know world of tanks i'm a pro
thank you you're welcome guys
this looks like italy
i've been spotted i see you [ __ ]
i have no idea this head ow ow
i love the swedish it's so good bush
tank
oh oh oh mexican huh this is a terrible
spot to aim but he doesn't know
he doesn't know
oh mexican don't know
oh is it hitting
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how i was going
you don't know how many [ __ ] times
i've died dude
getting two kills that's huge
i mean no i'm really good at the game i
swear guys it just comes
naturally where you going bro
yeah yeah my first victory
huge win look at that hey you're welcome
teammates
god damn oh
sweden i'm sorry oh i'm sorry sweden
don't shoot i'm i'm swedish isn't gonna
work this time [ __ ]
don't matter wait am i dying
come on come on come on
that's kind of romantic if you think
about it the swedes died together
all right trying out uh british tank see
if it does any better
oh damn oh
he doesn't know i love this they're too
focused on everything else
can i oh oh
critical
[Music]
i think this is a pretty good spot wait
what the [ __ ]
oh does everyone have that or am i like
super op that's a real question
come on oh hello
all right decent decent really really
low come on
oh he sees me
i miss everything jesus christ oh oh
come on come on come on
come on reload reel out
i don't know what country ah okay i
could have gotten that
there we go
whoa he just drove in front of us
i did that on purpose what an idiot
hey hey hey
yeah well i still did damage just he
just drove right in front of me bloody
stupid in it
come on come on back up back up there
you go
[ __ ] i'm just waiting for someone to
peek dude
all right now it might be a good time to
go in
here we go here we go here we go
come on you can't shoot me
i think he's immobilized right he
doesn't know
he doesn't know he doesn't know
oh that's too [ __ ] oh
sorry greek i mean greece
he's coming up here isn't he
never peak is never peak or sweet
[Applause]
oh i got wait i hit him i mean of course
i hit him how did i hit him
i mean of course oh never peak sweet
never pick swede oh sorry
sorry french you had to be sacrificed
bruh bruh bruh oh
four kills [ __ ] dude i'm gonna win this
one
hey hey that's my best game
i don't think he gets any better than
that so i think i'm gonna
leave it on a high world of tanks it's
legit
it's fun i like him again you get a
premium tank
14 premium day so if you want to check
it out it's free link is in the
description
use code pewdiepie on check out i said
that thank you world of tanks for
sponsoring this video
see you guys next time bye bye